denise if you watched the super bowl and
of course we all did odds are you were
moved by the ad from
indeed which showed how the company will
be there as americans
trying to get back to work yeah and the
ad played a cover of the song
rise up and it was sung by las vegas
native christian
shelton kate houston sat down with the
singer and his family to talk about his
road to the super bowl
[Music]
it means so much to me that people enjoy
my voice enough
to think that i would even be good
enough to do a local commercial let
alone
the super bowl that's broadcast to tens
of millions of people
nineteen-year-old christian shelton is
the vocal powerhouse behind the indeed
super bowl ad
and i was like okay wow this is really
really huge
and especially for their first super
bowl commercial
ever shelton's journey to the big game
began in march of 2020 when he started
posting videos of him
singing to the app tick tock
in less than a year shelton has amassed
nearly 750
000 followers and has received
compliments from artists sam smith
lizzo and meghan trainor and i can't
believe that that many people
like want to see me all the time singing
but it's really it's really heartwarming
and touching
in january shelton was asked to record
his rendition of the song
rise up which he had previously posted
to tick-tock during the height of the
black lives matter protests
on sunday surrounded by his family
shelton watched his hard work
pay off just to see it on the big screen
in that moment it was just indescribable
i'm so proud of it it's his consistency
because nothing is gained without work
kate houston 8 news now boy that is
fantastic what a voice too
christian was recently recognized as
being a black tick tock trailblazer
for his leadership and efforts on and
off the platform for an
in-depth look at his path to the super
bowl you can hear the full interview
with him
and his parents his mom and dad on our
website eight newsnow dot com
i can't imagine the whole family
gathered around on a couple of couches
and they're watching and listening to
their loved one what a moment and i
think as i was just saying in the
commercial get him a record deal right
ted yeah and it what it's interesting
i'm sorry they were talking about
talking to me what's interesting was is
that it was a super bowl it wasn't just
a regular commercial it's just super
bowl
a lot of eyeballs wow right 62 degrees
are